[Musique]
bonsoir les amis oh mais tout me paraît
très calme ce soir du silence j'ai bien
l'impression que p'tit louis et mirabel
sont déjà couchés
je mets au dormantes et hop on ne fait
pas trop de bruit pour ne pas les
réveiller ou vous pouvez me faire
confiance patron bon
ben alors et à personne donc c'est moi
qui l'attend et aux dominos regarde
regarde le poisson que j'attrape et fait
attention qu'aux autres ya beaucoup
tourné dans la mer sur un bateau
olalalala que d'eau
j'ai attrapé poisson vous avez rencontré
avec ulysse non seulement qu'il ait pris
de nous fait moi aussi je te dis que
c'est moi qui fais magamootoo toi tu vu
l'avantagé aux je ne veux pas voyez les
bras
je vais monter dans le bateau
voilà dans le bateau
[Musique]
maintenant besoin eurent porté attention
là il est reparti dans l'eau et il est
très content d'être dans l'eau d'imagés
il fait aussi dodo
quand il est à nant à côté de vous et il
ne faudra pas faire de bruit pour ne pas
le réveiller
[Musique]
allons bonne nuit ni petit poisson rouge
qui joue ni à huy mimi revel
[Musique]
en temps mais vous vite mirabel et p'tit
louis et toi aussi petit poisson rouge
et vous les petits enfants allez vite
vous coucher et si vous êtes bien sage
nous reviendrons sans faute pouvoir
demain soir
boni à demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
à demain